Ante las amenazas que se cierren
sobre el espacio natural de urdaibai,
lo que estamos proponiendo es IR 1 Paso más allá
de simplemente
luchar para frenarlas,
estamos yendo a proponer
1 medida jurídica
que realmente prevenga y blinde esa protección.
¿Cómo planteamos brindarla?
Planteamos brindarla
a través de dotar a urdaibai
de personalidad jurídica propia.
Esto es, 1 es 1 nueva
estrategia de protección de la naturaleza
que se está poniendo en marcha
en muchos lugares del Mundo
y que llegó en en llegó a España a través de 1 ilp,
1 iniciativa legislativa popular
que los vecinos y vecinas del Mar menor
propusieron y llevaron al congreso de los diputados.
Esta iniciativa en el Mar menor
lo que hizo fue que finalmente
se aprobara 1 ley,
la ley del Mar menor,
que blinda sus sus derechos frente a cualquier agresión.
¿Qué derechos puede tener 1 ecosistema?
Se pregunta mucha gente,
pues por ejemplo,
el derecho a su conservación,
el derecho a su preservación,
el derecho a su regeneración,
a la restitución
de los espacios naturales,
es realmente 1 nueva forma de dotar,
de blindar y de dotar de protección
al espacio natural,
en este caso de urdaibai, y por eso planteamos
que o bien a través de 1 ilp,
como se ha hecho en el Mar menor,
o bien a través de 1 iniciativa política
en el Parlamento Vasco, en el Parlamento Nacional,
se llegue a esa a esa nueva figura jurídica
que blindaría definitivamente
al a urdaibay y eh Plantearía finalmente
evitar cualquier tipo de agresión que pueda sufrir,
como la actual agresión
que está que se cierne sobre sobre el daibai,
que es ese proyecto de Google Jaim al que eh,
la sociedad civil
se está poniendo de manera muy eficaz,
de manera muy efectiva,
pero que desgraciadamente
desde el PNV se sigue impulsando y se sigue planteando